all right as we continue with the great
one mark levin his new book
american marxism is uh out tuesday it's
uh
on amazon.com we'll be in bookstores
next week everywhere
uh and a big driver of the democrats far
left turn is the indoctrination we see
it in the media big tech our nation's
universities give me one second here
mark
and and i want to just lay out something
fundamental i've been on radio as you
know 33 years i've been here at fox 25
years
i've been a consistent conservative i've
changed some views but
not a lot very consistent and
conservatism if you break it down
to what it what what we believe as
conservatives we
we believe in liberty we believe in
freedom
we believe in capitalism we believe in
our constitution
we believe in low taxes less government
regulation
constitutionalists on the bench we want
free market solutions for
issues like health care and yes protect
pre-existing conditions
we we believe in law and order and
safety and security so people can pursue
happiness
we want choice in schools we want energy
independence
for national security reasons and for
the economy economic reasons
we want our borders secure we want free
and fair trade
and we believe in peace through strength
i might have missed one or two things
now when you look at a poll one that
came out this week
a lot of young people 18 to 34 so split
almost evenly
there they find redistribution new green
dealism
socialism leftism authoritarianism
marxism even appealing why
why do you think bernie sanders wants
free college for all students
because these are indoctrination mills
we're not teaching mathematics and
science and physics the way we used to
now how do i know that because i read
what these professors write
and you can ask your own kids who go to
college or many of you at thanksgiving
you
send your kids to college they come back
and you don't recognize them
this is why they want to wipe out
student loans this is why they want
free college for all this is why they
don't regulate
tuition prices what goes on in
classrooms what these college
empires build and so forth they regulate
everything except two things
trial lawyers and colleges and
universities
and one of the things i suggest in the
solutions section is my book
it's time to get our hands dirty and
dirt under our nails
we don't need to continue to fund these
universities and colleges mostly through
state
taxing but also federal grants and of
course tuition
and pretend we have no say on what the
hell goes on in these classrooms
how are faculty chosen how are faculty
tenured
how are classes determined how are books
determined
what's going on on these campuses at
least republican legislatures
should they start to claw back shouldn't
there be oversight
should we start to pull money away from
these universities if they're teaching
our children to hate
us hate this country hate faith we are
doomed
so there is no reason for this so in the
book i lay out
a plan for taking on these colleges and
universities
you know we have power we have power in
numbers
we have power and resources we don't
have to sit back and watch this anymore
and say oh my lord what's happened to my
kid what's happened to your kid
we're sending our most precious thing
our children
into these institutions and they're
coming out and we don't even recognize
them
who do you think is in the streets who
do you think it is that's protesting to
overthrow this country
there's chapter and verse in this book
what they're being taught
who's doing it they how they dehumanize
and de-individualize their word
they want to create revolutionaries they
brainwash them on mob
action they brainwash them on protest
techniques
they even encourage them to be violent
they teach the marxism
in neo-marxism it's going on and you
and i are paying for it now what do you
say we do something about that
that's just one little example
and i want people to understand here
we're really only touching the surface
the detail and specificity on each of
these
issues that you are mentioning and
listing you go into great detail and
explain
specifically how how they'll use climate
change
as a mechanism how are universities as
it's used as a mechanism
um the wording the language the media
the institutions uh that they use
um i don't want to get ahead of myself
here
now that we have identified the problem
in the next segment we're gonna get to
what the solutions are but more
importantly i want to ask you this
you said in liberty and tyranny you said
in the past one of your past books
that we are in a post-constitutional
america
do you still believe that and can we get
it back before we get to our next ch
before we get to our next segment which
is you know how to
choose liberty and and save this country
in many ways we're in a
post-constitutional america
we just had an election in two lawsuits
in pennsylvania one in particular
in which the lawsuit said apart from
machines apart from ballots apart from
all of it
that the constitution makes abundantly
clear clear in article 2
section 1 clause 2 that the state
legislatures make election law in the
states particularly as it applies to the
selection of a president and vice
president
so we have a state of pennsylvania where
the governor where the
secretary of state and where the radical
left
supreme court elected supreme court
changed
the laws the election laws in
pennsylvania at the urging of the dnc
and their lawyers
to help the democrat party and the
democratic candidate
think of what you will about all the
rest of it that is a prime
case for the supreme court to take up to
interpret whether or not
these entities within the state had the
power to undermine the republican state
legislature
change the election laws in violation of
the federal constitution
and to the best we can tell only two or
three supreme court justices wanted to
take up that case
we have a very very weak separation of
powers now it's been under attack by
these so-called progressives for a
hundred years
they only believe in the courts when
they get the reactions and the answers
that they want they only believe in the
elections when they win them
otherwise they attack it s one
h.r one the entire purpose is to make
permanent the democrat party and
eliminate any influence any opposition
party
or the republican party has they want to
pack the court they want to pack the
senate
they want to change the legislative
process they want to destroy the
electoral college
they want to open the borders the
problem in this country is
just like marxism it's party first
country second the democrat party has
more in line with the ideology of some
of these marxist parties
than the american people want to admit
that is
party first party power party
influence you have to kill the
constitution kill it
if you have to rearrange the government
rearrange it if you have to issue 420
executive orders issue 420 executive
orders
if you have to spend six trillion
dollars to strengthen your party to
strengthen your movement then
do it because the party is the way to
power and the party controls the country
that's their mentality hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else